you
[Music]
so it's my pleasure to have introduced
and have Kevin here talk to us today
so Kevin she is from Carnegie Mellon
where he works with Phil Gibbons and
owner he's done some really interesting
work at the intersection of systems
architecture and machine learning
in fact he's interned here with
grannyish Peter and Mota he's worked
with all of them I think Renee she was
mentor and he'll be talking about some
other work today both sort of serving
systems as well as training systems and
Kevin and I for some time have been
actually working together now looking at
training models using data where you
have non-id data and I think you'll
touch upon that do today um so we're
very excited to have you here came in
welcome okay thank you for the
introduction tomorrow so today I'm going
to talk about my research on designing
machine learning systems for highly
distributed and rapidly growing data
feel free to interrupt me if you have
any question okay I'll begin a talk with
a very quick overview so as we all know
the explosive development of machine
learning has enable many interesting and
important applications such as face
recognition object detection
self-driving car level generation and
many other more and at the core of these
machine learning applications are two
key machine learning phases which are
training and serving so a training site
we usually typically collect a set of
training data and feed them into a
machine learning training system to
generate a machine learning model and
then we will feed them into a machine
learning serving system to answer
questions based on the serving data for
example we can train the image
classification model based on a set of
images then we can answer questions such
as what type of aperture is this image
so the key objective of both training
and serving are low latency and low cost
low latency is very important for
training because it can typically take
hours or even days to train a model and
the serving size is also very important
too
low latency because they're serving is
usually part of user facing service so
the latency will determine the usability
of their service locales on the other
hand is also very important because it
determines that uses a practicality and
feasibility to deploy machine learning
application however when we deploy
Imagineering applications in a real
world we have to pay more attention on
those training and serving data this is
because in the real world a lot of
machine learning data are actually
generated at rapid speed at different
places for example many large
organizations like Microsoft or Google
deploy many data centers all over the
world and many machine learning data
such as images videos user activities
are generated at different places as a
result those machine learning data can
be highly distributed and rapidly
growing and they can pose new challenges
for machine learning to achieve low
latency and low cost so give you a more
concrete example let's first look at the
serving site and then how rapid growing
data affect serving for example we can
have a lot of traffic cameras in a city
that keep recording videos that are
rapidly growing and then we can build
the machine learning serving system to
answer questions such as finally the
video frames for particular objects such
as charts so typically we have two
options here we can do all the
processing at ingest time for the live
videos but they don't incur high cost
because we don't even know if those
video will get queried on the other hand
we can do other processing at the query
time by the time that we know what what
we are querying for but that will induce
a long latency because all the work are
happening at query time the other
example is to look at training site
let's say we want to train a machine
learning model based on the data that is
geo teachability
when we do this the training will help
have to happen over the is wider than
networks which are typically much slower
compared to local area network within
each data center as a result this
training can become high cost and incur
high long latency if we do this sort of
training over yes
all the place yes it is
so centralizing data is I think more
typical way to do it but there are
issues with that for example you can for
some data that's too costly to move them
and also there was some low constraints
such as data sovereignty law that you
cannot move data out of EU for example
so there are cases where we will need to
do this geo disability training yeah
okay so in this talk I'm going to talk
about the machine learning systems I
designed for this highly distributed and
rapidly growing data our first introduce
focus this is a machine learning serving
system that aim to provide low latency
and low cost querying for rapid coding
data and I'm going to use video as a use
case this is also in temperature that I
did with connection some of you may
already know about it and the second
system are going to describe biscaia
this is a machine learning training
system that enable training over got2b
the data and make it as fast as training
within a single data center and finally
I'll talk about some ongoing directions
that I'm doing also with amar about
training over SKU data sets and also
some future work directions so I'll
first talk about the serving side and
focus so video is actually one of the
most replicas in data at this time
because we have so many cameras all over
the place we have traffic cameras in
cities we have home cameras we also have
monitoring cameras in retail stores
enterprises actually we have cameras in
this room many cameras here right now
right so one of the key applications in
machine learning enabled with over this
video is that we can query objects in
those videos for example a city planner
can may be interested in all the trucks
showing up in a city for a period of
time or if say there's a garage burglar
even happen in a garage then we may be
interested in other video frames that
with people in it so runny nose query we
need to use detector and classifier
cnn's which is usually
mostly in slow when we have massive
videos I win every on there very quickly
so one typical approach to enable this
low latency query as I say at the
beginning is we can do this ingest time
analysis which is when the live videos
are recorded and then we can just run
them through those expensive neural
networks and then we generate the index
the inverted index can be object class
member to the video frames then at query
time you only need to look up the query
but it sound object-- class that users
are interested in to return the friends
this approach will make query very fast
but the downside is it will be very
costly for example if we use the a
reasoned neural network like Yolo v2 it
can cost almost $400 per month per
string so imagine we have thousands of
videos to ingest it will be very high
cost on the other hand it is also
potentially wasteful for example the
bregma event that I discussed at the
beginning if we only we may be only
interested in a particular garage a
video but at the interest time we
wouldn't know which garage video we are
interested in so we have to analyze all
of them that can be a lot of waste so
the other approach is that we do nothing
at ingest time and then we do all the
WorldCat query time it was safe as the
cost of interest time and reduce waste
however and also we can further in
optimize that using frame down simply
skipping or using a query up query
specialized to CNN and tesak Adam will
say expensive CNN to make it even faster
in fact there is a state-of-the-art
system that's called noscope that does
exactly that
however using even using this kind of
specialized system for video it's still
very slow it's going to take five hours
to query a month long video so in this
world our goal is to enable low latency
and low cost squaring of a rapid growing
video data sets in particular you want
to build a system that can process a lot
of video streams and the user only need
to provide a expensive CNN and the
accuracy target and then at query time
use a query for particular objects and
we'll return the frame
so before yes you said five hours for
all the scenarios who describes seems
like that would be an acceptable delay
yeah five hours it for the scenarios you
described it seems like that would be an
acceptable way acceptable delay yeah to
it conducting a police investigation
six days doing the city planning
planning takes years yes I guess it
depends on the application for example
if we are if we are doing some for
example let's say if there is some event
happen in the city and we want to look
for this particular kind of car a
particular kind of truck then then the
latency requirement will be much higher
and also just in general as a service if
we provide a service that takes like
hours to run I think is just in general
not not good for most users services
where the event is triggered and a high
level you know there's an accident
detecting that in actually
triggering the saying inner language is
energy so assistive actually be notified
thank you wanted really that would
require month longer wouldn't refine
what love means so it depends on the
application yes yeah I was gonna say you
know if I have a really urgent query
it's probably over the most recent data
which bounced the amount of data I have
to an alliance to so I probably don't
have an urgent query over month long
video over months of video right if I
care about analysis of her older video I
can hopefully wait maybe you'll get into
this yeah so I guess yeah so it depends
on the application I agree yeah
but some applications is obviously more
later than C terrible yeah okay so
before I introduce the system I'll
quickly go through some key backgrounds
of convolutional neural networks so
there are two key aspects of
convolutional neural networks that I'm
going to introduce but the first thing
about this classifier on your network is
that we can actually see their final
layer output is actually the probability
of all the possible objects for example
this input image is a truck we can
actually get the probability of truck
moving van pass car etc and the other
aspect is that the layer before this
final output is with our feature layer
so this feature layer can be seen as a
high level representation of the input
image okay so now I'm going to introduce
the system we built we coded focus the
key idea of focus is that we neighbor
low latency query with the low-cost
ingest it has three key components in it
and I'm going to cover the first two key
components today the first key component
is that we enable approximate indexing
using chip ingest
so the idea here is that instead of
using expensive CNN to analyze those
videos we can just use cheap CNN's
instead for example we can use the CNN's
with fewer layers fewer weights or the
seen and specialized for each video
streams in particular when the videos
come in which
shred the frames and objects brung them
through instead of running through
expensive CN n to generate the index we
just replace them with specialized and
compress C and then to generate the
index but there's a problem with this
approach which is that there's a there's
a reason why those cheap synonyms are
cheap because they are usually less
accurate to be more precise let's say
with the input image here as a truck if
we compare the output between chip CN N
and expensive CN n we can see that the
expenses CN n is correct say it's a
truck but the chip CN n is wrong say
it's a moving van so to solve this
problem we make empirical observation
which is that we find that the best
results within those for those expensive
CN n is actually within the tab key
results with these chip cnn's and the
case are usually small for example here
if we look at the third output of chip
CN n we can see that the truck output
show up in another word we can actually
use tab key results to compensate for
the accuracy loss of those cheap CN n to
be more precise we use two metrics to
define the accuracy targets one is a
recall Rico is the fraction of objects
we can find from overpopulation and
precision on the other hand is the
correct object return fraction of the
corruptors will return to a user based
on the results that we give you to user
let's first look at how we can keep the
Rico high so here we study a particular
video in the y-axis is recall and X s is
a number of output we select from those
cheap CN n we compare those cheap CN and
output which is based on less than
eighteen and remove these four layers
and six layers to a more expensive CNN
as Yolo v2 that can recognize eighty
classes so if we look at the foot tub
outputs from those cheap cnn's the
recall is actually horrible it's
actually 50% or less than fifty percent
so it's actually not very useful and
also the chief of the ceiling we go the
lower reco we will get but the
interesting coming out here so actually
if we pick k equals two to the recall of
sudden becomes reasonable here we get
more than 90% of the reco by only pick
two results from those cheap cnn's and
if we pick k equals to three or four
we can actually get more than 99% of the
Ricoh which is the accuracy is enough
for many applications in another word
those cheap CNN's can achieve high
recall with a small type k results but
there is a problem of this approach
because when we pick more than one
results from those cheap CNN will return
more results than we need to to the user
so the precision will become lower so
how do we keep the precision high as
well so the solution is we develop a
split architecture we're at inches time
we mean uses cheap CNN to analyze those
videos to generate a top K index
against from object class to object an
object to frame so at query time when we
know which object we are interested in
we find out those objects and map match
the in the index and then we run them
through the expensive CNN to make sure
they are indeed those objects and then
we'll return to the user so with this
architecture we still maintain high reco
using cheap CNN and then we get higher
precision by doing some work at query
time and more importantly those create
time worker is only done with the videos
that were actually interested in so
there are much less waste the other
component is that we enable fast query
with redundancy elimination so as we see
we use this approximate interesting
approach to do a chip ingest but that
introduced a non-trivial work at query
time and actually the larger the K we
select there will be more credit and
work to do
to solve this problem we make another
observation where is we already process
all these objects with the chip CNN so
we can actually extract the features
from the feature layer of those CNN's
cost is between say is it 80 percent 99
percent 12 percent of us so overall it
can be up to 50 times difference 50
years
right so we should extract those
features and there's a lot of study has
established that images with similar
feature they will be visually similar so
we can actually run them through some
clustering algorithm and then so cluster
similar objects for example here there
are the same object with different video
video directions but we can using this
approach to cluster them together and
then add query time you only need to run
this expensive CNN once per cluster
instead of every objects so we can make
the query latency even shorter
so the incorporate is clustering and
into our architecture instead of
generate hub K index directly from chip
CNN we first we've tried the features
and around them through clustering
algorithms and then we also get the tab
key results from the centroid of each
clusters and then at query time we just
pick the clusters that match the query
object and then round the centroid
object through the expensive CNN and
then we will return the frames if
they're match from other clusters so
with this approach we can reduce
redundant work at query time we evaluate
our system using eleven live traffic
enterprise videos each video is it
twelve hours and the accuracy targets we
do is 99 percent recall precision with
regarding too expensive CNN you know v2
and we compare with two baselines one is
inject that basically the two that I
discussed at the very beginning in just
heavy that interested everything using
the expensive CNN and interest time and
stored inverted index no scope on the
other hand is a query only system
they're optimized heavily for the query
you know v2 is a relative reason reason
object detector CNN that I think they
win some competition for I think this
image image neck objective agent
competition
CNN that you're cutting that you're
using and cutting later so yeah so
that's this step baseline that's because
when you shut those numbers before the
recall for the yes I CNN was like fifty
five percent or something right it was
not so so this is ninety nine percent of
fifty five percent I mean it's not your
job to fix the CNN right you're not
research oh so at the beginning the
results I showed it's actually the
comparison between cheap CNN recall so
the base right but you should the
baseline in there - it wasn't really all
great read the Green Line you know I
think there's the fish no no forgive me
was one but he also showed three things
which is the full CNN one with four
layers this one no no okay so maybe I
misunderstood
yeah this one so the green one is to
rest in there 18 this is not a place
like this is already a chip chip chip
CNN and then this is removed four layers
six layers so they are cheaper and
cheaper so there are three chip cnn's
and compare with the yellow v2 that's
expensive one so we we assume what you
know you know b2 can get it sequentially
so I agree that explain that so yeah I
understand right okay so even the green
one there's a cheaper yes as much much
cheaper then and then you made it you
made it cheaper even let you in yet okay
so it wasn't that you saved 50 X by
chopping out six layers you save through
DX by going to a cheaper nor network and
then current data yes all right that's
not thank you it's nice you were yeah
yeah when you heard this light a hard to
tell you paid people like I don't know
what your w-2 is so uh general is this -
I'm saying how whether your example is
just example for slide where or if that
this is so let's say I wanted to query
for all the Toyota Tundras or the
suspect was wearing a loyalist
sweatshirt with this work so right now
we we based on objective Tector CNN that
they use much general
classes such as people or cars or truck
moving man stuff like that but you can
imagine you can train another kind of
network
that can recognize more detailed classes
or you can even abuse some service on
top of that for example you can find
cars first and then do some sort of
histogram to find gray car blue car like
things like that but but it's not so in
this particular work evaluation we did
is based on yellow v2 that recognized
general classes but you can imagine you
can trim you only look to do a
convention of how well how do how much
of your results are an artifact of the
fact that you have unlimited set of
things to choose from and how much would
the users also generalized to a much
broader set of things that that you
might not even have anticipated that's a
good question so in our evaluation with
mostly based on Yolo v2 but we also did
another evaluation is based on rest net
152 there's significant eyes actually a
thousand classes but obviously that's
still not the precise example that you
say but we sort of try to try to show
that it's not just because we can only
recognize 80 classes so it's easier
we also 2000 classes and we see that
it's actually quite applicable to that
situation as well
okay all right so let me just quickly go
through the end-to-end performance
so here the y-axis is interesting the
y-axis is query latency and excellent
access is ingest cost so obviously a
smaller would be better if we plot
interest heavy here it will be very high
interest cost but almost no correlation
see no scope on the other hand is very
high per latency by knowing just cost if
we plot no scope and this figure it will
be here we also have a zoom in figures
that's with different trader of options
so although we can see that no scope is
actually 57 times cheaper than average
compared to ingest heavy I focuses their
focus and the query latency if you
compare against no scope is an average
of one hundred and sixty two sixty two
times faster so now the query will
become two minutes for a month on video
rather than five hours and - yes it
seems like if I need to get its answers
within minutes of time yeah okay don't
need to search video it seems like the
more likely cases you know some of that
happened and I want to look at what
happened over the past 24 hours or the
past 12 hours yeah six hours okay so how
how does your system do if we consider
these sort of shorter videos or shorter
periods of time that I want to analyze
so actually there's the aspect that I
didn't have time to cover this that is
actually you can see it here that
actually focus can optimize for
different kind of settings so we can
actually so if we don't really care
about all that much about crazy latency
we can actually choose options that
optimized for ingest cost so we can
actually pay even smaller ingest cost to
achieve what's the latency requirement
that we want to achieve for example if
we operate in general only care about
one day or several hours of videos so we
know that we can do the pig look at the
envelope calculation that how long
basically was a latency there will the
target that we were going to achieve the
movie actually
even cheaper CNN to do the ingest and
then to achieve the latency requirement
but if we use no scope there is just no
such flexibility because this like this
fixed latency and maybe it's okay for
certain applications but it's not okay
for other applications so they recorded
the 30 frames per second but with all
the evaluations done based on one frame
per second are you actually going
through 12 hours and you're hitting the
99% precision recall targets yes let me
know if it's an uncooperative pencil
that's the answer it doesn't want Haas
to anything to do it see mine as well
and the fact it's good fully it's gonna
free honey is very much so I might as
well right I mean 1% precision accuracy
it will make any difference right okay
so to demonstrate the this system we
actually build a a demo system here that
okay so this is focus and here we show
an example video that's called chorus so
basically it's a it's an aquarium and we
can see there are sometimes people
showing up and stuff so if we let's say
there's some customers to say that I
lost my handbag and I want to find
handbag in these videos so with no scope
there's no process pre-processing at
ingest time we can run this query and
obviously and no scope has to analyze
all these friends so they'll be around
10,000 frames each to analyze it's going
to take a while actually to run and so
obviously we don't want to or we can
come back to that later but it's going
to take a while so yeah
so it's running on the server scmu yeah
so this is only the webpage yeah okay
and on the other hand we can also do
Focus which has some pre-processing then
we can do the same query but right now
that we can see that the analysis only
need to run over 200 each frames because
we already filter out most of the frames
at the beginning and then we can get
those videos come back right away right
and you can see that for example we can
see there are some hand back here a bit
of small ah right you can see this back
here are here actually this is where the
handbag show up right so the we the
object detector very accurately captured
this and there's an other examples you
can see handbag right and if we come
back to this still not it's not
happening so it's going to take a while
really
so actually before this talk actually
run this the same query with no scope
baseline and we can see that after it's
done it's going to take almost eight
minutes to run in the same results exact
same results with no scope yes Wednesday
to the left yeah yeah what's the ratio
of having our timing at the x-axis
what's the ratio in cost between focus
and there's ago so no scope is almost on
the scope there's no ingest cost so it's
if you want to the ratio is our total
cost I don't have the number of top of
my head I believe it's around 20 times
difference
could ask the pastor if it's only
queries you probably know one one you
pay on queries when you pay on in just
right but some of the eggs might be
okay right so there's other applications
for this as well
any large and growing data using CNN can
use this approach for example there are
many other video applications like face
recognition in motion detection scene
detection they can also use similar
technique and audio so you may want to
find some keyword with within the audio
or bioinformatics we want to find
certain principles with certain
characteristics or even geo-informatics
right we have several images we want to
find or track
certain objects then we can also use the
similar split architecture that we do
some pre-processing at ingest time so we
can save the query time significantly
you said that you tried it with your end
object that's it and here the hypothesis
is that you can extend it to all these
different correct yep so that's like
what have you actually tried it even on
toy examples there your difference
actually
and others okay so now let's move on to
the training side and I'm going to
introduce kiyah
so as I say at the beginning there were
times that we want to train a global
model by leveraging the data generated
at different there are centers so by
doing this the typical approach s
Canisius asked is that we can move the
data into one data center before we do
the training however as many prior work
has argued that this centralizing
approach is usually invisible for two
reasons one is that moving those data
over wire network can be very slow and
costly and the other issue is that there
are some times theta 70 low constraints
like you may not be able move data out
of EU so the alternative approach is we
can do this training over different data
centers and we deployed the machine
learning system geodesy little early
however all this communication has to
happen through a wide area network and
based on our study it can slow down the
system by more than
fifty three times compared to training
within a single data center so the goal
in this work is we want to develop but
got2b the system that we can minimize
communication over a wide area network
and we can return the accuracy and
correctness of the machine learning
algorithms also with no change for the
algorithms and machine learning programs
so before I go through the solution I
would like to give a quick background of
distributed machine learning
architecture in particular the parameter
server architecture that has been
adopted in many machining systems so
from very high level we would like to
train the machine learning model based
on the training data with this parameter
server architecture we will partition
the data into multiple partitions and
using different worker machines to
handle each partition and then we can
also have multiple parameter servers to
collectively maintain the machine only
model waits at the end of each iteration
or mini-batch the worker machine will
generate update to the weights of
parameters to the parameter server and
then we will get back to the most
up-to-date parameters so we can generate
an next next iteration update this
synchronization extremely important for
the accuracy and correctness of most
those machine learning of algorithms so
when we deploy this architecture and
wide area network the most
straightforward approach is we can have
the worker machines in different data
centers to handle the data and then we
deploy the parameter servers in
different data centers however with this
approach all the communications from
local worker machines to remote data
centers has to go through a wide area
network and as I say at the beginning it
can cause very high slowdown so to solve
this problem we introduce a system that
we call Gaia
the idea of Gaia is with the cupholder
synchronisation model within the data
center from the synchronous model
between different data centers
specifically we still have the working
machines in different data centers to
handle the data and we have parameter
servers in different data centers as
well but the key difference here is that
we in each data center we maintain a for
and approximately the correct model copy
because it's a for copy so the
communication
but in worker machine and parameter
service only to happen locally to make
progress in different data centers will
have another approximated correct copy
and we will use another synchronization
model here to make sure they're within
some acceptable difference with this
approach we can we only need to
communicate the significant updates that
change to the weight and we can
eliminate the insignificant ones so to
see why this architecture can help us we
study the update significance so here we
studied three machine learning
applications metric factorization
tapping modeling and image
classification so they cover traditional
machine learning how supervising
learning and more recent new network
many so the y-axis here is the
percentage of insignificant update and
the access is that we choose different
threshold for the significance for
example 1% means that if the update
changed the weight by more than 1% we
say it's a significant otherwise it's
insignificant so as we see even with
with even we choose a relatively small
ratio 1% more than 95% of the updates
are insignificant which means that
because the vast majority of them are
insignificant using our kaya
architecture we can eliminate most of
them and to make sure that all these
parameter servers still synchronize
appropriate appropriately we introduce a
new synchronization model that we call
approximate synchronous parallel so
there are three components here I'm
going to cover the first two the first
part is the significance filter where
the working machine generated updates to
parameter server and in the server we
maintain the value and also the
aggregated update forever Fadel
thermometer and those update will keep a
gated into this aggregate updated field
and the end of each mini batch or
iteration we will send a value and
aggregate update to a significance
function to generate the significance of
this aggregated update and then we will
compare that with against a significant
structure so if it's larger than this
ratio we say it's a significant and then
we share them with other data centers
otherwise we'll keep them locally so the
significance function can be as simple
as the ratio between aggregate updates
to the
you we can imagine that there can be
some other more complex significance
function and the significance ratio will
have initialized value let's say one
person and we will apply some function
to make sure that the ratio gets smaller
and smaller over time so eventually we
order data centers can see all the
updates in the second component we call
SPS relative barrier so we need this
technique because even though we only
send a significance update they can
still arrive too late so obviously if
you said the initial significance the
threshold too high then the training may
diverge at the beginning so it has to be
relatively small and we can you can find
out those Thresher by doing some local
local child error using the data that
locally and then run entire system
locally to find out what the threshold
I'm going to use and then you can apply
that geodesy beautifully yeah yeah yeah
so our default schedule is actually we
we change the threshold based on how
many day changes most updates are in
communication that is - yeah
all right so so instead of just sending
the significant updates we actually
first send a barrier that tell other
data centers that all these parameters
are going to have significant updates so
the local workers have to not reading
them until the significant updates
arrive so with this approach we can
actually let the workers that not
dependent on those parameters with
significant updates to keep going on and
other workers have to wait so to
evaluate this system we we evaluate
three applications measuring
vectorization
tablet mangling image classification we
deploy our system on Amazon ec2 and we
also use some local cluster to emulate
the wire and network bandwidth we also
match the performance of our system with
a real easy to deployment will compare
with the two parameter server systems
deployed over wider in the work all the
results I show here they achieve the
same accuracy as that we can do it with
BSP within a local data center oh yeah
okay PSP is that the the communication
model that I described at the very
beginning they would communicate
everything all the time okay no no yeah
but we do check that with the with the
emulation that we did compared to the
real deployment that a performance
difference is with in fact there are
some algorithms like lasso that is
actually it only care about certain ways
it based on the data so for some data
they only care by part of the weights
they don't care about all the ways all
the time but there are some learning
algorithm like new network for example
then you care about all the weights all
the time because you you need to look at
the way to generate the forward backward
pass so for neural network that
these approaches only sent selectively
barriers is not very effective because
you only need other ways anyway unless
there's no significant updates in this
connector then you can move up yes so
you're considering significant sort of
per update basis yes but you could
imagine sort of accumulated significance
over time sort of like we last synced up
and the values for this right and then I
have a bunch of insignificant aces but
that leads me into a place where I've
made a significant advance that's right
so you could force the sink about what
that is correct so that is why we call
it aggregated updates so the epic at
that they won't get reset so it will
keep accumulated even if it's small
it'll keep accumulate accumulated until
it reaches the point that's significant
and it will communicate that way yeah
it's an extreme case this one okay yeah
so this extreme case we just hope you
know you have this potential and you're
also certain things addiction but in
that approach I think he was very
restrictive than one okay fine yes
binary decision yeah okay so let's first
look at the training time so so first we
evaluate a setting there between
Virginia California so it's within the
same continent why does it work and the
y-axis is training time so as we can see
compared to baseline kya is much faster
and also very close performance to land
which is that we train the algorithm
trained the same algorithm with the
preloaded data within a single data
center and we also exam the setting
where is between Singapore and South
Paulo
this is the worst wire network pair we
can find between ec2 data centers and we
can see that in this challenging
approach we can still see the guy I
pretty much can close up the gap between
lang and baseline
even in the most challenging case where
we run an image classification we can
see the kyer can achieve more than 50
speed up over baseline is very similar
performance to lane and although it's at
most one point to three times of the
lane speeds we also evaluate the cost of
running this on ec2 so here we see
commend the cost into three parts one is
the communication cost of a wider than
the work and also the Machine costs are
waiting for network and also the Machine
cost they do the compute we first look
at the machine fertilization was
different
wider than what wide area network
setting y-axis is the cost and we can
see that in all settings Gaia is much
cheaper mostly because we eliminate a
lot of communication cost in a time that
waiting for the network and it's pretty
much the same with other applications as
well overall kaya can achieve up to 59
59 times cheaper compared to baseline so
before I go to the third work I'll
quickly summarize some key takeaways
which is you didn't tell us how much
accuracy tomorrow's lose by doing this
as opposed to there's no loss so yes I
say at the beginning so other reports
results are reported based on accuracy
that we can achieve within the secona
cinco de la Serna
okay so doing this training we're so
like if you say vary the threshold at
some point well but we are reporting the
thread show that doesn't so if you make
the threads over you have say 50% then
obviously it there will be some loss but
so there are two two key insights that
why it doesn't
so first is that at the beginning of
machine learning training there were a
lot of updates happening and at that
time even the threshold is high is still
it's still kind of fine because it's
we're not fine-tuning to the optimal
point and then at the at the very end
obviously it's very important that we
find the optimal point and but at that
time the learning race usually is much
smaller which means updates itself are
much smaller moving with much smaller
updates and we - our threshold to make
it smaller as well so
eventually they will converge to the
same point or similar points we actually
have some theoretical justification for
that as well for Congress setting but
for non-convex setting obviously is much
harder to analyze but for come for
Congress I think we actually have a
theoretical proof for that this actually
it works no yes you have all these
deserts are marching baseline actions
that's right so don't these three are
actually non convex oh three so cocky
modeling is not even whatever Congress
is its unsupervised and for
virtualization and image classification
there are none Congress at all but we
still see that the accuracy is still the
same with what we can achieve within
single dataset so how does it compare to
this alternate baseline and the
alternate baseline you don't have any
coordination between the two data
centers and very two entirely separate
models right and your model is first
tell me which data center this data was
generated closest to and then apply that
halls great question so so so that first
of all that depends on actually
something I'm going to discuss very
quickly but they'd ask you but they say
there's no tsq and we actually did that
experiments with face recognition so if
we have for the full data set or part of
data set or quarter of the data sets we
can see that the performance actually
drops significantly so it is important
to have the view of the food data set
but on the other hand if there's a major
that has skew then there's a different
story which our combination yeah yes
your time is already very close to
answer maybe this question is but I'm
wondering what could you just do all of
this a seven element like could I just
sort of apply updates to my server and
then in the background
it also swaps updates with other
fragrant or servers and they all kind of
get jumbled together and applied so I
never actually have to block after I
make an update waiting to synchronize
with some other machine it's all kind of
done asynchronously
so that's this model that called total
synchronous parallel there's actually
well for the thinking hog-wild that
that's exactly that but that actually
been proven that only works for certain
algorithms for example for neural net it
just doesn't work at all yeah yeah and
you just diverge very quickly
Peterson for cluster if you run the ESP
not communicating there has beaten work
from others I have shown this to people
so got results showing that these be
touching much because see this
divergence yeah yeah so the beginning
when you're doing a justification for
this you need two justifications yeah
one is you didn't want to centralize the
data and the second one is that there's
something expect totally by the second
one those are we suffer under GBP are
all that's fine okay but for the first
one
how's the pillow data transferred for
your system compared to just centralize
it very good question we had this line
for that yeah
yes good so yeah so we're gonna do the
comparison so compared to a centralized
approach so this is actually the speed
so if it's more than yeah it's over
centralized so right so it's more than
one that means that kya is faster right
and there's a cost ratio as well so you
can see that if we only look at the cost
part then it is it is true that
centralized over sir
yeah yeah so how it runs faster
sometimes but is really worth it yeah
yeah okay so so the only reason to do
this is in your scenario 2 which is GPRS
that will make more sense but but that
also depends on actually I think the
data set size in the model you know how
many iterations have to run so it's a
function of that but we only evaluate 3
so you can imagine in cases where the
model is relatively small compared to
the data then it will make more sense
even the under cost right right ok ok so
to summarize we can see that this highly
distributed and replicating data can be
very challenging for both machine and in
serving and training and our approach is
with design machine learning systems
that take advantage of some
characteristics of machine learning such
as the algorithm for example gaya we see
that updates are not significant most of
the time or machine any model structures
like the tab key results or the feature
layer of this chip cnn's or the training
serving data crystals for example there
are some similarities in videos so we
can see that by using this approach we
can reduce latency and cost of machine
learning serving and training by one to
two orders of magnitude other than
machinery and systems I'm also
interested in computer architecture
problems so I also made contributions
for processing memory input including
two projects that I let and also cross
related abstractions for both CPUs and
GPUs and also different systems as well
I hope people are happy to talk about
these projects with you if you're
interested
so now I'm going to quickly go through
our ongoing effort that I work with amar
for the SKU data sets so most
literature's in machine learning
distributed training assume that data is
randomly distributed however it's just
not true for the real world data sets
for example face recognition the face
will actually determine on determined by
the demographics of different countries
so it can skew over space and also it
can skew over time as well a different
time will have different demographics
and different compositions of the data
so the question we want to ask is what
will happen to machine learning if the
data is skewed over time or space so
first we look at the space and we do a
comprehensive catalyzed Asian's with
different machine learning applications
with different decentralized learning
approaches and different kind of skill
data skewness so here I'm going to show
results with image classification and
face recognition and we are doing other
more and I started three decentralized
learning approaches including Gaia and
other two very popular decentralized
ending approaches that reduce
communication overhead the way that we
create skew data is essentially we for
simple image classification we put
different image class to different
places face recognition is the same we
put the pictures of different people in
different places to see how this skewed
data affected model quality we look at
this particular example of Google net
over size for 10 so the y axis is type 1
validation accuracy which is the you can
see it as the model quality and for the
shuffle data we can see that for all 403
decentralized approach they match the
accuracy with PSP very well is exactly
the same however if it's skill data the
story is totally different for all three
approaches there's a majors accuracy job
with them in another word all these
existing discern disinterest learning
approaches don't really consider this
setting and they can do significant
accuracy with the pedaling with this
kind of data and the other hand PSP
which is we can communicate everything
all the time it can be accurate but it
would be too slow if the communication
is the bottleneck we observe the same
results across the board
example different in our network with
the same dataset we can see the same
results with skill data we also tried it
with different datasets imagenet and
pretty much the same results we also try
with different applications face
recognition they using different very
different kind of validation scheme but
the results is pretty much the same so
essentially this problem is actually
pervasive and it found very fundamental
for machine learning training especially
for those decentralized learning
approaches and what make it worst is
that actually for certain neural network
even using PSP can solve this problem
for example ResNet that we can see that
even PSP lose some significant accuracy
and our study shows that it's actually
the new networks with passion
normalization layers that have this
problem so the immediate direction that
we are looking at is how to solve this
problem so the idea we have is that
since those decentralized learning
approaches maintain different model at
different places we can actually do a
periodical model travelling which move
model from one place to another and we
can use the training data in a new data
center to test the quality of this new
model and then we can learn if there is
some accuracy gap between different
models at different places we can use
that as a proxy to see how that has how
much data is killed and also we can
learn another thing which is which data
samples are creating these accuracy
drops and then we can do two things
in the case where by local training we
can remove the data we can tighten the
communication based on the skewness or
accuracy track that we learnt and the
other thing we can do is that to say if
data movement is possible then we can do
selective data shuffling it's like
active learning so we can pick the data
samples and we think creating issues for
my data center so that we can be more
communication efficient and then do this
training with the skill data and we also
looking for solutions for neural
networks with nominalizations as well
and obviously this is a simplest case
right so there are other case where the
data can also skewed over space and time
at the same time so we are looking at
interested in the duration where is
continuously learning that we keep
learning distributed ly but the data can
skew over time
so we need to be able to detect whether
they'd have change and then
incrementally and efficiently update the
model because we don't want to return
the model when the data has changed by
the same time we don't want to lose what
we have learned with this old model and
also we want to tailor to the provision
requirement because some or some
application will be interested in more
recent data some application will be
interested in the global knowledge of
all the data that we have seen and the
other thing actually there's a question
that was asked by Jay as well that the
trade-off between local model versus
goggle model right because sometimes
it's actually making more sense to just
train the local model and then because
it was much better for the skill data
anyway right so the question we are
going to ask is is it possible to Train
global model and local model at the same
time so one one idea that we we can look
at is the idea called multitask learning
essentially for example you can think of
an internet you can train the bottom
layers globally so leverage the data
everywhere but the top layers we can
specialize for different places so we
can do this training at the same time
and we can use the same idea or
potentially other ideas but it has to
also change over time so there's another
dimension we have to look at and looking
even down the road I'm also interested
in different machine learning paradigms
like reinforcement learning auto ml
which search the neural network
architecture automatically for a set of
training data and see how they play with
rapid growing distributed and skewed
data for example reinforcement learning
is not clear how we can build a
communication efficient reinforcement
learning system and that attempts to
skill data over space and time because
reinforce learning usually assume that
you can go and simulate your model with
get some reward and then you said to
come back and do the training but if
that the data is spread across different
places so you will get different reward
different time then how do we deal with
that and also obviously change over time
is another problem
auto area on the other hand we usually
need to explore many many models to
achieve the optimal model which means
that we need to run the same training
for non the same shiny but run the
training for maybe hundreds or even
thousands of times then the questions
that build just
to make more sense right like then why
not essentialize the data but let's say
if we cannot do that then we need a more
cost efficient approach the idea one
idea is that we can train some local
model with different places and then try
to find a way to merge this model and
then find a way to do that and the other
direction is that how does this distance
the center is learning approaches
interact with Auto ml because with Auto
Meter we don't even know if certain
model will converge right but we also
use his communication efficient approach
that may create other problems for
accuracy as well so there's another
dimension that we have to figure out but
if we don't use those approaches the
latency will be just unbearable right so
there is a trade-off between cost
latency and accuracy so there's another
interesting direction that I'm
interested in okay so with this
technology of my quarters throughout the
years thank you I'll be glad to take any
more questions knowledge of spatial why
not used the machine learning model the
machine learning training to figure that
out automatically by providing as one
feature at the time that data was
collected or at the data center that was
not sure about questions so yeah saying
just so I mean my mind machine learning
algorithms are panacea that can learn
anything and maybe they could learn the
result the the way that the model should
change based on depending on what data
center the demos collective in and or
what region of the world and the time
defective so why not just let the
machine learning model do its thing by
just supplying as one additional feature
on it on each data on each down to add
one more feature saying this is the
place part of the world it was going
through them another feature saying this
is the time it was collected in and just
let the ML algorithm figure out the
spatial temporal dependence
okay so there are good questions so for
the for the space part so if we are
interested in training specialized model
for different places that approach may
work but there are cases where we just
want to leverage data at different
places that so it's not so important
that where this data comes from but it's
more important about what's the content
of the data and how can we leverage the
data so even adding a feature point to
the neural network may not actually help
on the time so actually time is very
challenging because machine learning
training is that we begin with some
random model and we already converge to
certain model at some point right so at
that point moving a model is not as
simple as you know just getting some
more data in and then you can you know
restart because you have to consider if
we move out of the optimal point then
how about the old data right this
there's actually a term for it is called
kiddos traffic interference that we we
learned for the new things but we forget
about the old things right so it's a
very interesting problem and some people
are working out that were like creating
memory in your network and you know
doing some different kind of things but
it's still a very new area I was sorry
it's not a new area it had been proposed
like in nineteen eighties but there are
a lot of reason work they're working on
neural network with catastrophic
interference it's just it's just one
problem of that right the other problem
is how do we even update the model that
we can efficiently reach a new optimal
point that without sort of consider all
the data right without retraining
everything
are there other questions well if not I
think a lot lot of you're actually
meeting in one-on-one so let's hang
speaker again
[Applause]